>> THERE IS SOME BREWING
ANIMOSITY BETWEEN SOME WHO ARE
NOT AT ODDS BEFORE, THE LIKES
OF MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE AND
NOW LAUREN BOEBERT, LISTEN TO
THIS.
MANU RAJU DID CATCH UP WITH
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE, THE
CONGRESSWOMAN FROM GEORGIA, AND
SHE IS NOW EXPANDING HER
COLLEAGUE CONGRESSWOMAN LAUREN
BOEBERT.
LISTEN TO.
THIS >> I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, NO MATTER HOW YOU VOTE,
ARE SICK AND TIRED OF DRAMA AND
THIS IS NOTHING BUT DRAMA.
WE ARE ON MULTIPLE DAYS NOW
WITH MULTIPLE CANDIDATES FROM
THIS GROUP AND SO I'M NOT SURE
HOW LAURA BOEBERT ON ONE HAND
CANNED DEMAND SO MUCH OUT OF
KEVIN MCCARTHY AND THEN DEMAND
NOTHING OUT OF SOMEBODY ELSE
AND BE WILLING TO VOTE FOR THEM
TO THE SPEAKER.
THAT IS NOT SERIOUS, I DO NOT
THINK THAT IS LEADERSHIP AND I
REALLY SEE IT AS MORE
OBSTRUCTION THAN AS PROGRESS.
>> DRAMA.
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE A
MISTAKE TO THINK THAT, EVEN
AFTER THIS AND EVEN THOUGH THEY
ARE ON OPPOSITE ENDS ON THE
MCCARTHY QUESTION FOR SPEAKER,
THAT THEY ARE SOMEHOW ON
DIFFERENT ENDS OF THE
IDEOLOGICAL SPECTRUM.
LAURA BOEBERT AND MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE ARE IN THE EXACT
SAME PART OF THE IDEOLOGICAL
SPECTRUM WITHIN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THEIR ELECTION BUYERS, STAUNCH
TRUMP SUPPORTERS, THEY ARE BOTH
PEOPLE WHO HAVE REALLY SHOWN NO
INTEREST IN NECESSARILY BASIC
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS AT ALL,
WHICH WE'VE TALKED ABOUT.
SO I WOULD THINK THAT THEY
WOULD PROBABLY VOTE SIMILARLY
ON GOVERNMENT FUNDING BILLS, ON
DEBT LIMIT BILLS.
WE'VE SEEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN
WHERE MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
AND LAUREN BOEBERT ALIGN ON
VOTES.
>> THIS IS THE FORK IN THE ROAD,
IN OTHER WORDS?
>> THIS IS WHY IT'S SUCH A
MISTAKE TO LOOK AT THESE 20 AS
A FRINGE.
THE GROUP IS MUCH BIGGER, THEY
ALL WANT TO INVESTIGATE HUNTERS
LAPTOP.
THEY WANT TO HANG FAUCI.
THE GROUP IS MUCH BIGGER THAN
20.
>> THE DIFFERENCE IS TACTICAL
AND STRATEGIC.
THE LARGER GROUP SAYS THAT WE
THEY WANT TO DO THIS STUFF, BUT
WE CANNOT GET TO IT UNTIL WE
ARE SWORN IN.
AND IF MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
PREVAILS AND HELPS KEVIN
MCCARTHY BECOME AN EXTREMELY
WEEKEND HOUSE, SPEAKER SHE IS
GOING TO BE MUCH MORE EMPOWERED
THAN LAURA BOEBERT OR MATT
GATES.
>> SHE IS SAYING THEY CAN DO
THAT WITH KEVIN MCCARTHY AS
SPEAKER, THAT IS WHAT MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE IS SAYING.
AS OPPOSED TO LAURA BOEBERT.
>> IT IS A MAGA CAUCUS.
IT'S NOT JUST THESE 20, IT'S
THE BEGINNING OF IT.
>> STOP COUGHING.
>> SO EMOTIONAL, LOOK AT YOU.
>> TALK AMONGST YOURSELVES.
>> IT'S THE EVE OF JANUARY 6TH,
AND MORROW AS THEY RECONVENE IT
WILL BE THE TWO YEAR
ANNIVERSARY AND WE ALL LOOKED
AT 2022 AND SAID THERE WAS BEEN
A BIT OF A RESET, THE PUBLIC IS
SICK OF GAMESMANSHIP AND THEY
WANT TO MOVE ON AND THEY
RECOGNIZE LEGITIMATE RESULTS OF
THE ELECTION, AND JUST
JUXTAPOSING THAT MOMENT WITH
SOME OF THE MOMENTS OF EARLIER
TODAY, DONALD TRUMP USING TRUTH
SOCIAL TO TROLL WITH HIS PHOTO
IN WHICH HE IS THE MACHO
SPEAKER --
THINGS IN SOME WAYS, THE
COUNTRY CAME OUT OF JANUARY 6TH
ON A COURSE CORRECTION.
AND THEN IN SOME WAYS THE
COURSE CORRECTION HAS NOT
HAPPENED AND.
THAT STILL PLAYING.
OUT >> MY EARLIER POINT, WHICH
ACTUALLY GETS THIS, 18 OF THOSE
20 ARE ELECTION DENIERS AND
EVEN MORE THAN THAT THERE IS A
BUNCH ON MCCARTHY SIDE THAT OUR
ELECTIONS BUYERS.
SO AGAIN, TO JOE'S POINT, BAKED
INTO NOW THE CULTURE OF THIS
REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE IS THAT
THEY ARE NOT NECESSARILY
INTERESTED IN DEMOCRACY OR A
FULLY FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY ALL
THE TIME BECAUSE THERE IS
DOZENS OF PEOPLE THERE WHO
VOTED AGAINST CERTIFICATION.
>> WHICH IS WHY AGAIN, LAURA,
THE MOST IRONIC THING ABOUT ALL
OF THIS IS THAT IT ALMOST
DOESN'T MATTER WHO THE SPEAKER
IS BECAUSE WE ARE STILL GOING
TO HAVE ALL OF THE
INVESTIGATORY STUFF, WE'RE
STILL GOING TO HAVE A DEBT
LIMIT.
THERE IS NOTHING ANY SPEAKER
CAN DO TO STOP ANY OF THIS >>
THERE'S A RECKONING THAT HAS
NOT BEEN RESOLVED, AND WILL NOT
BE RESOLVED WITH THE OBSESSION
OF THE HOUSE SPEAKER.